please welcome last year's academy award
winner for best actress nicole kidman
a passionate romantic a grown-up bad boy
with a temper
an older commanding patriarch a pirate
and a man in a midlife crisis
for women these are the five stages of
dating in hollywood
for oscar
they are the characters created by
five extraordinarily talented actors
the nominees for best performance by an
actor in a leading role are
johnny depp in pirates of the caribbean
the curse of the black pearl
ben kingsley and house of sand and fog
jude law in cold mountain
bill murray and lost in translation
sean penn in mystic river
and the oscar goes to
sean penn
this is the first academy award and
fourth nomination for sean pan
he was previously nominated for his
leading performances in iron sale sweet
and low down and dead man walking
thank you um
if if there's one thing that actors know
other than that there weren't any wmds
it's
it's that there is no such thing as best
in acting and that's
proven by these
great actors that i was nominated with
as well as the
as well as the jimmady's
cages downey juniors nicholsons etc that
were not nominated
we know how great all of you were
my
daughter dylan and son hopper find it
presumptuous and embarrassing to write a
speech and so
i'm gonna give it a go without um
god i i really thank uh clint eastwood
professionally and humanly uh for coming
into my life
the great great cast that i had to work
with
my friends
where do you go dennis lehane
brian helgeland
ma
dad
and
robin
for being an undying
emotional
inspiration on this roller coaster i'm
learning to enjoy
thank you all very much
you